muy buenos días pues hoy continuaremos
escuchando el testimonio que escuchamos
ayer por la noche que empezamos a
escuchar ayer por la noche de uno de los
pilotos de jeffrey este que trabajó para
él durante 28 años identificó ayer a
maxwell como una persona cercana en
siempre con una relación más personal
que profesional dijo que su labor era
vital para el mantenimiento para la
administración de estas casas y
mansiones que tenía jeffrey state además
aseguró que viajaba mucho con el
multimillonario fallecido y aunque no
era una prioridad sí que había una lista
bastante precisa de quién utilizaba esos
aviones hoy continuaremos escuchando su
testimonio en este proceso que está
previsto que dure entre seis y ocho
semanas en el que beasley maxwell se
enfrenta a 80 años de prisión y en el
que escucharemos los testimonios de
cuatro presuntas víctimas que acusan a
maxwell que en colaboración con éste en
abusó sexualmente de ellas cuando tenían
tan sólo 14 años el jurado escuchará
también el testimonio de una empleada
que hablara sobre una libreta que al
parecer contiene los nombres e
información de las víctimas así como de
las celebridades
millonarios que se subieron a esos
aviones y participaron aparentemente
presuntamente en esos abusos sexuales
con maxwell y con epstein